Hi zusammen! Wir machen heute ein weiteres Brot in unserer Subway Reihe.
Ich hab mir überlegt - also die Wahl lag echt zwischen Vollkornbrot und Honey Oat.
Und ich habe dann in meinem Umfeld recherchiert und jeden genervt und auf Whatsapp jeden angeschrieben:
"Hey, was würdest du eher bestellen? Vollkornbrot oder Honey Oat?"
Und ja, die Mehrzahl lag dann eben bei Honey Oat und deswegen habe ich mich ein bisschen durchgetestet
und habe das für mich perfekte Rezept herausgefunden.
Hamza, ich hau dich jetzt in die Pfanne!
[Hamza] In welche Pfanne?
[Kiki] In unsere!
Nein, ich hau dich jetzt echt in die Pfanne! Hamza hat gerade geschrieben:
"Honey Out" und ich fand das so süüß!
[Hamza] Oh neiiin! Ja, das war diese Rechtschreibüberprüfung!
[Kiki] In deiner aktuellen Story!
[Kiki] Ich weiß, ich fand das richtig süß!
[Hamza] O-A-T, ich weiß Leute!
[Kiki] Honey Oat, genau. Wir machen jetzt -
[Hamza] Ich bin so ein Opfer!
Honey Oat, also Haf -
[Hamza] Jaja, ne?
[Kiki] Honig.. Ja, Karma!
[Kiki] Honig.. und Oat, das ist glaub ich Hafer, oder?
[Hamza] Ja!
[Kiki] Also Honig-Haferbrot.
[Hamza] Nein, "out" heißt das! *kichert*
Honey Out! Okay!
Wir machen jetzt als Allererstes folgendes vorab, das habe ich erledigt:
Haferflocken - grob oder fein ist egal - richtig schön fein mahlen.
Die müssen richtig schön fein werden und jetzt geht's los.
Ich hab 'ne kleine Verletzung an meinem Finger und nehme jetzt meine Küchenmaschine mit dem Knethaken
und knete dann mit der einen Hand gleich ein bisschen weiter.
Aber ihr könnt auch alles mit der Hand kneten aber so geht's natürlich ein bisschen einfacher.
[Hamza] Ich kann dir auch helfen.
[Kiki] Ohh, ja!
[Hamza] Nein, das wird sich ziehen. Das Video soll sich nicht ziehen.
[Kiki] Ne, ne, ne, ne, das hast du jetzt schon gesagt!
[Kiki] Hast du die Kamera angemacht?
[Hamza] Ja!
Okay, jetzt mache ich hier erstmal lauwarmes Wasser in meine Schüssel
und gebe da schon Honig mit dazu und das Gute ist:
Dadurch, dass das Wasser lauwarm ist, kann sich der Honig da richtig schön miteinander vermengen.
[Hamza] Wie unprofessionell, dass du fragst, ob ich die Kamera angemacht habe!
[Kiki] Ja, wir sind ja auch kein professionelles Filmstudio zum Glück!
[Hamza] Sieht das nicht nach Professionalität hier aus?!
[Kiki] *lacht*
Jetzt kommt Olivenöl mit dazu, dann ist es sogar ein palästinensisch angehauchtes Sub!
[Hamza] *lacht* Einfach Kanake!
Als nächstes geben wir Mehl dazu.
Behaltet noch ein bisschen zurück, dann können wir das nach und nach dazugeben.
Außerdem Salz, frisch gemahlenen Pfeffer und Trockenhefe.
Ich benutze heute Trockenhefe, natürlich könnt ihr auch frische Hefe nehmen.
Ich schreibe euch sowieso alle Infos und alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
[Hamza] Infobox! *lacht*
[Kiki] In die Infobox.
So, und dann einfach langsam kneten lassen und anschließend wie gesagt mit den Händen weiterkneten.
Und zwischendurch gebe ich ein bisschen Mehl dazu
und dann merkt ihr schon, wann die perfekte Konsistenz erreicht ist.
Der darf nämlich nicht mehr kleben.
So, das Hafermehl gebe ich jetzt auch schon komplett mit dazu.
So, der Teig ist jetzt perfekt. Also er darf nicht mehr kleben,
er darf aber auch keinesfalls zu trocken oder rissig sein.
Das ist super, super wichtig. Und jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen von dem Olivenöl in meine Schüssel.
Schön verteilen, dann den Teig obendrauf
und dann nochmal mit Olivenöl benetzen damit er auch nicht austrocknet.
Ein Tuch drüber legen und 45min lang an einem warmen Ort möglichst ohne Durchzug gehen lassen.
So, als nächstes - uiuiuiui, der ist aber gut aufgegangen!
Als nächstes teile ich den Teig durch 3
und forme den schonmal so ein bisschen länglich, geb's auf meine Baguetteform
und dann nochmal zugedeckt 15min gehen lassen weil das ist echt wichtig
damit's später richtig schön luftig wird wie bei Subway.
So, 2. Gehzeit ist rum.
Ich hab jetzt hier ein Gemisch aus Honig und Wasser und pinsele das jetzt einfach oben drauf
und dann kommen typischerweise noch ein paar Haferflocken auf die Oberfläche.
Und jetzt Leute, ganz, ganz wichtig: Backofen immer schön vorheizen
und zwar auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und dann brauchen die Honey Oat Baguettes so ungefähr 20 bis maximal 22min.
Und anschließend bitte zugedeckt ein wenig abkühlen lassen,
ihr könnt's natürlich auch noch warm genießen.
Lecker, lecker, lecker! Fertig!
[Kiki] So und jetzt auf jeden Fall.. zudecken!
[Hamza] ...essen!
Und dann essen! Wir machen ja daraus Chicken Teriyaki Subs.
Da freue ich mich schon riesig drauf!
Ich verlinke euch alle meine Subway Rezepte in die Infobox
und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Viel Spaß beim Nachbacken und hinterlasst diesem Video auf jeden Fall ein Däumchen nach oben
wenn euch die Subway Reihe gefällt.
Schreibt mir unten in die Kommentare, welches Rezept nicht fehlen darf und dann mach ich's einfach nach.
Und dann würde ich mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!